[Music]
so as I crashed into the cold dark water
of the Pacific I realized a few things
hey I have no idea where I'm going be
saltwater stings see I shouldn't even be
on this planet right now but I am why
because you shot me I know you shot me
all right I heard you the first time you
know I have to pile it on good grief
I'm wet I'm cold there's a fish on my
head and clearly I'm not gonna be able
to do this on my own all right get in
the truck really you can help me I guess
it is a little bit my fault that all
this is happening to you not a little
bit entirely it is entirely your fault
it's entirely my fault are you coming
yes road trip
what am i doing I'm sonic a little blue
ball of super energy in an extremely
handsome package and in order to save my
planet I had to come
wherever what yours it is the rock
president 20 minutes ago an energy surge
knocked out power across the entire
Pacific Northwest who's there
why are you hiding out in my garage the
entire military is after me good morning
my rural chump I'm going to give you
five seconds to tell me where it is
[Music]
happening me oh my god stop the car
right now the world's largest rubber
band ball we gotta see it no this is not
some fun family road trip Yeah right it
was lame gift shop was cool though you
can lay low here for a while so what are
we gonna do now whoa let me show you how
it's done
[Music]
so should we get out of here yeah time
to go
you won't get away from me oh you've got
car insurance right
god
no but thank you for asking
[Music]
how are you not dead I have no idea
[Music]
would you throw your life away for this
silly little alien he's my friend
good times
that was an illegal left by the way and
I'm using it to protect
glad
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal that is very
gross
[Music]